- [Voiceover] Stacy wants to find
the derivative of f of x
equals x squared plus one
at the point x equals two.
Her table below shows the
average rate of change
of f over the intervals from x to two
or from two to x, and
these are closed intervals,
for x-values that get
increasingly closer to two.
so they get-- so we're talking about
the average rate of change of f
over these closed intervals
for x-values that get
increasingly closer to two.
It looks like we're going to be dealing
with some type of a limit,
or we're trying to calculate
some type of a limit,
or approximate some type of a limit.
Let's read this data here.
These are the x values
and she's trying to find
the average rate of change between each
of these x-values and two,
or the average rate of
change of the function
between when x is--
one of these x values and two,
and then she has the
average rate of change
that she precalculated,
so we don't have to get a calculator out
or anything like that,
and just as a reminder, how
did she calculate this 3.9?
Well, they tell us.
She took f of 1.9,
what does the function
equal when x is 1.9?
From that, she subtracted
what is the value of the
function when f is equal to two,
so that's really our change in f,
and she divided it by
the x, which is 1.9,
minus two,
so change in f over change in x.
What is the average rate of change
of our function over that interval?
She did it between 1.9
and two, she got 3.9.
Then she gets closer to two,
so now she's doing it between 1.99 and two
and it becomes 3.99,
it looks like it's getting closer to four.
She gets even closer to two
and the average rate of change
gets even closer to four,
and then she goes on
the other side of two,
you could view it as this is approaching,
this is-- this is approaching--
this is x approaching two
from the left hand side,
and this is x approaching
two from the right hand side.
When it's 2.1, the average
rate of change is 4.1.
When it's 2.01, once again,
we're getting closer to two,
the average rate of change
is getting closer to four.
The closer we get to two,
the closer the average rate
of change gets to four.
What this data is really
helping us approximate
it's really saying, okay,
the average rate of
change we know is f of x
minus f of two,
over x minus two,
but what we're really thinking about is,
well what is the limit as x approaches two
right over here?
That's what this data
is helping us to get at,
and it looks like this
limit is equal to four.
They give us it in here, it says,
"Look, the closer that x gets to two
"from either the left hand
side or the right hand side,
"the closer that this
expression right over here,
"which is this number, gets to four."
You might recognize,
this is one of the
definitions of a derivative.
This is one of the
This right over here
would be f prime of two,
the derivative at x equals two
is equal to the limit as x approaches two
of all of this business.
There's other ways to express
a derivative as a limit
but this is one of them.
There you go, from the table,
what does the derivative
of f of x equals x squared plus one
at x equals two appear to be?
Well, the derivative at x equals two
appears to be
equal to four,
and we're done.